Samantha wrote in yr classic books
classic does this really have any
objective meaning or value I have strong
feelings about this PAP you've read a
lot of the classics right
yeah even just from high school and
college assignments I've read a good
amount of the classics the pictures that
you see behind you there yeah I probably
maybe not every single one of them but
I'd say 70% okay so here's the thing uh
I don't think that there's any objective
moral value to enjoying the so-called
classics and this can include everything
from you know Gone with the Wind we
could be talking about the Odyssey we
could be talking about works by
Dostoyevsky I don't fall into this idea
that if you don't get great pleasure out
of reading some of those there's some
kind of moral assessment to be made
about you I think at the same time that
because we are very desensitized right
now because of all of the books fiction
nonfiction movies TV shows etc that we
can sometimes lack context when you pick
up Crime and Punishment by Dostoyevsky
it might just strike you as sort of
boring because you've been desensitized
by so much of what we now consider to be
source or the normal media available
today but what you have to consider is
that at the time at least for example
with crime and punishment this was one
of the first novels that focused so
heavily on the inner dialogue of the
character Raskolnikov and sort of the
internal the psychology of what was
going on inside his mind right I mean it
was it was um it was groundbreaking in a
lot of ways and so if when you read it
you're thinking about it not as how it
elated mi by paid the page-to-page of it
but sort of the broader context in which
this novel was created I think you'll
certainly get more out of it but I don't
generally buy into this idea that hey if
you're not just riveted by Beowulf
there's something wrong with you I tend
to shy away from criticisms like that I
also just think that some of these
classic novels are his
lessons in a sense because the great
gatsby for example speaks to the
prosperity of the 1920s and it really
just captures the zeitgeist of that time
and I think you can pick out many
different examples and it's also maybe
just important to read the classics
because it gets to a point where
everyone else is reading them so you
want to understand the references that
other people make I have 1984 is being
talked about a lot for in the world
especially in the era of Trump now so
you want to just be able to have an
important role in those conversations
and because you know it's kind of a
cycle in the sense that everyone else is
reading them so you jump on board to
with it but because it's just brought up
in normal conversation you should also
take part in reading them this same
thing happens with old movies right like
a lot of people say you know Casablanca
oh my god I tried watching it I was just
bored out of my mind I don't get what's
so good about it and you have to
understand the context of what was going
on at the time you have to understand
what was innovative about it from a
production standpoint and yeah you know
reasonable intelligent people can still
be bored and not care about it it
doesn't make them bad people but I think
it's a really good thing to be able to
if you understand the context of some of
these great works you can get a lot out
of them and I think there's a lot to be
said to that yes lesson of the day is to
read a book I guess we adolescent of the
day okay that is lesson of the day okay
we've got a fantastic bonus show for you
today I'm out of time but what I can
tell you is david pakman.com slash
membership is how you sign up you can
also pledge even just a dollar or two a
month to support the work we are doing
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
we will speak to you on the bonus show